in a small office in Buenos Ires a black
market deal is
underway if they're caught those
involved could end up in jail but it's
not drugs or weapons being sold it's
money despite the risks deals like this
are common place in Argentina's capital
and they are one in a long list of
economic woses like
hyperinflation president menm inherited
a country in economic and social
disorder Bank runs even an ex-president
found guilty of defrauding the state
Fernandes has dismissed the trial as a
Witch Hunt the problem is that as we
normally say Argentina is the country
that never misses an opportunity to miss
an opportunity argentine's frustration
with the economic dysfunction saw the
rise of a radical presidential hope for
in the 2023
election
Javier M wants to dollarize the economy
a move he says would blow up the central
bank but the change that Argentina needs
will take more than one man the main
reason Argentina's economy is so chaotic
is because of consistent economic
mismanagement over decades without big
Solutions things could get much
[Music]
worse events of the past few years have
been difficult for the world economy
this is going to be a tough year tougher
than the year we leave behind this
financial storm hit when Argentina was
already in
Peril to understand how bad it is for
South America's second largest country
take a look at
inflation countries like Britain have
experienced annual price Rises on par
with the world average in high single
digits Argentina's inflation hasn't been
that low in decades the rate has been
higher than 100% for almost all of 2023
right now only Venezuela and Lebanon
have higher rates and it's really hard
to kind of just imagine what that's like
for some people they just can't make
ends meet
anymore inflation this High forces many
argentines to get creative argentine's
save in dollars because saving in local
currency in a local bank has been a
recipe for disasters even this isn't
easy right now argentines can only
legally buy $200 a month at the official
exchange rate that has created a vast
black market for currency dealers line
the streets of the city
center while people hoard stashes of
cash at
[Music]
home but buying dollars on the black
market Market is more expensive than the
official
rate El Flo is one of a handful of
bosses in Argentina's currency Black
Market he's agreed to talk to us on
condition of
anonymity he claims the black market has
tacet
[Music]
approval with a GDP of $630 billion US
Argentina is one of the largest
economies in South
America but this booming Black Market is
a symptom of just how bad things are and
the roots of the problem Run
Deep the main reason Argentina's economy
is where it is today is
historical once one of the richest
countries in the world there are many
reasons behind Argentina's decline
including the legacy of this man pan
Domingo
Peron elected president in
1946 he came to power after having been
inspired by melini's fascist Italy
basically what he took from fascism was
a strong State that's very intrusive and
a strong emphasis on
nationalism and he combined that with
also having a very strong labor movement
he introduced the 8-hour workday
increased wages for the poor and created
vast expensive welfare schemes he also
embraced economic
isolationism the emphasis on National
sovereignty led to kind of the coddling
of workers by protecting them from
foreign competition it has shut itself
off from international
trade today Argentine politics is still
dominated by his legacy peronists have
been in power for
of the past 20 years one of the issues
with with peronism is they they haven't
evolved with globalization and with the
world Argentina's exports have shrunk as
a percentage of global exports year
after year in the mining sector
Argentina has one of the largest
reserves of lithium and also it's very
rich in Copper just to think that Chile
is the biggest copper exporter in the
world and Argentina produces zero copper
and we share the same mountains as well
as remaining isolated from the world
economy the government also still hugely
overspends on things like price
subsidies the average European spends
around $40 a month on
electricity the average Argentine spends
$5 eight times
Less in 2022 alone this cost the
government $ 12.5 billion around 2% % of
Argentina's
GDP but government laress goes beyond
welfare of the 13 million people in
formal employment in Argentina over a
third of them are employed by the state
itself a lot of spending goes on paying
salaries and pensions you actually
wanted to go on things like investment
technology infrastructure helping the
poor rather than paying public wages all
of this point to the main issue in
Argentina's economy Argentina has been
running a fiscal deficit for the last 13
years if you're in a difficult time for
13 years in a row well you have a big
problem policies to counteract this
deficit like printing money only make
things worse governments have become
dependent on the Central Bank printing
money to basically Finance spending and
the more money you print the worse
inflation
gets local shopkeeper Martha Valdez
feels the direct impact of more money
being pumped into the
system putting more money into
circulation can mean it's worth
less
[Music]
printing money is only one way the
government tries to fund its spending
another is borrowing so Argentina has
borrowed a lot of money but it has also
defaulted so many times that people
don't want to lend it money anymore more
despite the risks there is one
institution that continues to
lend today Argentina's debt to the IMF
is more than double that of Egypt the
second highest borrower all told
Argentina holds almost a third of all of
the imf's total lending one of the
criticisms that most economists have
opposed to the IMF is that the
conditionality that they put to
Argentina was so so light they didn't
need to stabilize the economy they
didn't need to do any homework and they
receive money I think that was another
Miss opportunity for Argentina borrowing
and printing money are not unusual
tactics for governments but the extent
that Argentina's government does both is
Extreme and damaging in part because
loans from the IMF need to be repaid in
foreign currency and one tactic
Argentina employs to get that foreign
currency only complicates things more
trade
restrictions soybeans are one of the
country's biggest
exports the soybean producer in
Argentina they face an export tax of 33%
if a tone of soyan cost say $500 I
receive $500 minus 33% leaving the
farmer with
$335 they then have to exchange these
dollars for pesos at the the official
exchange rate when the dollar rate is
bad Farmers have to make harsh decisions
the incentive is to keep your soybeans
in your silos and and until the exchange
rate uh changes if everybody does that
the supply of dollars in the economy is
scars so the government invented
something that we call the soybean
dollar the soya dollar is a slightly
better exchange rate specifically for
profits on soya exports
but it's not the only Market with
confusing
rules if you want to um organize a
concert in Argentina and and bring a a
British singer you have to pay the
official dollar and then an extra tax we
call it the dollar call
[Music]
[Applause]
playay if you want to travel abroad you
use your Argentine credit card and you
pay the official Dollar Plus taxes and
we call that the dollar Qatar this idea
of having 10 15 20 different prices for
the same thing doesn't make any sense
that's a distortion with the set of
distortions is impossible that Argentina
grows over the years different
presidents have proposed different
solutions to the economic conundrum but
the outcome tends to be the same more
debt and more
inflation it's really really hard to fix
Argentina's economy and that's because
many of the things that we've talked
about are linked everybody agrees the
government needs to spend less one way
to do that is by reducing subsidies but
if you do that you're going to push up
inflation everyone knows the currency
needs to be devalued but if you devalue
the currency that will also push up
inflation so it's really hard because
tackling one part of the puzzle means
that things could get much worse before
they actually get get better as the 2023
presidential election
approaches it will be difficult to
convince a disillusioned population that
short-term pain will bring long-term
prosperity the real heart of the problem
is trust if Argentina cannot win back
the trust of its citizens or the trust
of the markets it's never going to be
able to fix its problem and in order to
build trust you need to have good
policies for decades not just for a few
years not just for one
government thanks for watching 2023 is
an election year here in Argentina and
I'm going to be covering it extensively
so if you want to read my coverage and
watch more videos like this please click
on the link and don't forget to
subscribe